do you like that we are going to be
trying the fur bow which is a nanny cam
for your dogs
there's the capability to look at your
dog to talk to your dog into the third
treats for your dog while you're at work
I have two pugs technically because I
recently moved out they are my parents
dog but in my heart they're still my dog
dog's name is Olivia she's a mini
dachshund my dog is named Hadley I have
always wished that I could text her when
or apart just to be like hey how are you
doing but I can't do that because she
doesn't have a poseable thumb and the
ability to read or write which is a real
bummer I used to be able to bring her to
work every single day so that's been
rough on me I'm excited to sort of get
that oh my god I'm so excited to see you
reaction she refuses to get a job though
I want to know what she's doing with her
day hello from the floor of my parents
kitchen me and Sophie are exploring the
fur go right now I was worried it would
be an eyesore but it actually goes
really well with my stuff do you like
that it was through some steps saying to
get the dog acclimated
have them sniff it out I want to test
her in one of the treats to see how
Olivia reacts cut her sitting and
friendly fur bow because that's where
the treats came from I didn't realize it
through like five of them definitely
sort of just like the fastest Pug it
gets the treat but maybe that'll make
them exercise a little bit and now for
my least favorite car of the day leaving
her
what a beauty because now is the real
test to see if it can cure my pug
homesickness
so I just got another meeting and I'm so
excited to check on my fur boat I was
like so distracted just thinking about
how I just wanted to get back to my desk
to look at my dog but look at how cute
my dog looks are you can barely see them
me talking to our freaks are out I think
she keeps on going to the door to check
if I'm there and being confused so I
think I'm gonna not do that anymore
because I don't want to make her anxious
think she feels a little bit confused
when the camera though just focus I
think she can hear the sound and then
she'll just stare right up at the
cameras a little funny my family is
starting to get a little creeped out cuz
they'll be in the kitchen where the fur
bow is and all of a sudden it'll start
like gargling and spit out treats I feel
a little bad after the treats go up
because she's still looking at the
camera for a bit when I check back in
feels kind of sad I think I had given
her like something like 40 treats today
which is not great it's because the
thing dispenses five at a time and I
really wanted to know where she was and
if she was like hiding over the couch or
something what she was maybe it's just
this like longing to be with them that
makes them seem extra cute I feel kind
of like I'm invading her privacy night
mode like kind of creepy because I'll
like throw her a treat to see where she
isn't just out of the couch and all of a
sudden I saw the eyes pop out a little
weird seeing her glowing eyes she looks
scary there's like the twins from the
shining overall we definitely loved fur
bow oh you want a Bentley did basically
what I thought she would do which is the
alternate between sleeping on the couch
and sleeping under the couch I felt like
I was disturbing her I'd check in and
she'd just be doing her own thing
and then I'd be pelting her with treats
it did make me miss her more during the
day but that's honestly just the way for
someone obsessed with her dog I
definitely liked it more than my dogs
dude my dogs didn't dislike it but I
don't think they knew that it was me
talking to them she has complained about
her privacy rights and I don't blame her
[Music]